to fail where so many other pharma firms
have enjoyed such
sweet success is bitter and such a
downer in the fight against the
coronavirus
but thank goodness we've got more than
one vaccine because curabax
isn't up to scratch that's the result
from an interim analysis based on 134
covert cases
in a study with about 40 000 volunteers
in europe
and latin america germany's keurvak was
supposed to be one of the big players in
the fight against covet 19.
the european union had ordered 400
million doses of its vaccine
optimism was high earlier this year when
curavax ceo france venez
joined in a conference call with eu
health officials
we are planning to have a conditional
market approval
somewhere in end of may beginning of
june depending on the data of course
at the moment our data readout what we
can see
is that we can expect a high efficacy
there as well
and we are following certainly also with
variant
now the bad news stage 3 test results
have shown an efficacy rate
of only 47 percent far less than
vaccines made by competitors
and under the 50 minimum rate set by the
world health organization
markets reacted immediately with curvex
shares plunging at times
by almost half their worst daily
performance
since the company's august 2020 ipo
research will go on at curvax labs
but for now the company is unlikely to
play a major role
in the short-term fight against the
virus
let's see what chelsea delaney has to
say about this chelsea
how did it go so wrong especially
considering
how many have led the way
yeah it's really a spectacular rise and
fall for your kurovac if you
think back to the beginning of the
vaccine race kirbak was one of the most
hyped up companies out there
this was the company that the trump
administration tried to convince to move
to the u.s and exclusively
uh give the u.s their vaccines for a
billion euros it set off a huge
a row over uh vaccine
rights and who gets those and in the end
germany itself the german government
invested about 300 million euros into
the company and got it to stay here
but there was a lot of interest in this
vaccine and it clearly just hasn't
panned out one problem for
curavac is that they started doing their
clinical trial
clinical trials later than pfizer and
biontech so
most of their trials have happened this
year when we've seen uh
the explosion of a lot of variants that
have made it more difficult
for these vaccines so that's one reason
why their efficacy
rate might be lower than that of pfizer
and buy-in tech but at the same time
it's just
spectacularly lower and it's not even
clear if they would get
approval from medicines regulators if
they do submit it like they say they are
going to the
the european medicine agency says they
want a 50 efficacy rate
this is clearly below that the german
government doesn't seem to
be all that worried about its vaccine
drive
seeing this as a as a setback but what
about the global
race to backs the world
yeah so europe had bet pretty big on
this and they had been expecting over
400 million doses
but they say that they have really a
strong pipeline of vaccines now in part
because pfizer and biontec have really
stepped up their game and are producing
a lot here so
today we heard from the german health
ministry that this won't really upset
the the rollout here in germany probably
throughout europe but for the broader
world
as this vaccine was likely to uh
be a bit easier to distribute it doesn't
require the deep freeze
refrigerators that other vaccines do so
for the global race this is certainly a
bigger
disappointment our financial
correspondent in frankfurt chelsea
delaney
you